das ist friedrich merz partei rebell
aber er spricht nicht so sehr mit uns
märz
aber wie jedes jahr sagt ja für eine
schöne vorweihnachtliche tradition die
wir uns jetzt mal im genauer anschauen
persönliche bilder zum jahresausklang
wirklich nicht mit uns sprechen
[Musik]
immer wenn ich weg geschubst dabei mag
ich ihn so ist friedrich merz mit hatte
den 2 was ist weg also um es in der
terminologie der jungen union zu sagen
ist er doch starker typ
ich denke ja du bist in der finanz
branche tätig du könntest doch was
vernünftiges werden kauf dir nen porsche
von mir ausmachen lernen irgendwie geil
weil bei monaco kennen oder sowas aber
geht doch nicht nur junge aus das
schließt ja nicht alles aus weil das
geile an der junge union ist viel gesagt
eben nicht nur die politische
zusammenarbeit der politisch gute
konsens sondern eben auch die
gemeinschaftliche gefunden habe die
freunde und eben das zusammensein
einfach das was man im normalen leben
halt nicht so hat
aber eben nicht überall das ist das
problem
was ist es was die jungen menschen so
fasziniert an friedrich merz ist es der
sauerländer charme ist es die mods kohle
die er verdient hat oder dass er nicht
an kaka ist vielleicht so eine mischung
aus allem ich habe erst gedacht warum
laufen denen ich den weihnachtsmann nach
der verteilt ja wenigstens geschenke wie
fühlt man sich wenn man der guru ist der
junge union der heilsbringer und jetzt
heute hier liefern muss man hat den
eindruck die junge union stand wie ein
mann hinter friedrich merz und jetzt
diese enttäuschung also ich weiß nicht
ich hab mal entspannen unterstützt ach
so aber was empfehlen sie diesen jungen
menschen diesen verwirrten sehen zumal
mit einem nassen handtuch einfach mal
über den rücken ziehen oder kalt duschen
das sind doch die maßnahmen um die
wieder zurückzuholen die ich bitte sie
süchtig in unserer zeit sind nicht mehr
zeitgemäß noch im club
aber sie wissen was ich meine
wer sonst wenig märz ist jetzt gerade
auf den weg einen kaffee zu trinken
wie schmeckt so einem überirdischen
heilsbringer wie in allen kaffee
wenn dann eine satiresendung 1 sie
müssen daraus quote machen dann ist das
auch gut für uns das ist diese bodenlose
frechheit das führt nämlich dazu dass
diese verbitterung in der in der
bevölkerung gibt über uns presse
wir stellen nüchterne sachliche fragen
und von seiten der politik wird uns
vorgeworfen dass wir denen nicht
ertragen wenn sie nüchtern sind was
macht dann der normale mensch der mir
jetzt jetzt vielleicht wird mit unserer
vollen dass wir ja im herbst wird sich
merz kommt und aufbegehrt denke da
wieder eingefangen und und das ist
eigentlich eine schöne vorweihnachtliche
tradition dort kann ja tradition ist für
konservative parteien haben cdu auch
richtig und wichtig von daher würde ich
mir wünschen dass kommt jedes jahr
wieder plan
das kommt jedes jahr wieder das bild
kommt und mit diesem persönlichen
ausblick wünschen wir allen zuschauern
des zdf frohe weihnachten vor
weihnachten alles gute ihnen und ihren
familien
guten tag könnte ich sie für ein abo des
heute show youtube kanals begeistern
ließ gefälligst ein abo ab